en direct on parle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
bah Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est tous les
jours hein faudrait lui enlever x même y
même tout hein Jean-Luc Mélenchon tiens
il y a moi j'ai un tweet j'ai j'ai un
message intéressant je vous faire réagir
là-dessus une personne une amie qui me
dit il faut pas oublier euh que son
parti est le seul qui défend les
musulmans il y en a aucun qui le fait
oui même si c'est de l'intérêt après
c'est de la politique de toute façon
c'est pas vrai qu'est-ce que vous dites
pas vrai
ils était où ils étaient où la France
insoumise quand le ramasse dans la bande
de Gaza défénestrait les homosexuels il
cétait où la France insoumise quand la
population de Gaza s'est révolté contre
le ramas qui sont une dictature
islamiste dans la bande de Gaza nulle
part pas eu un tweet tous ceux qui sont
en train d'agiter la sociétéour vous
êtes les républiain est-ce que vous
défendez les musulmans nous on a mais
nous on défend tous les Français parce
en fait le problème le problème si vous
voulez de Mélenchon c'est quoi c'est que
il a fait une stratégie qui est de dire
il me manque 400000 voies c'est ce qu'on
tout à l'heure et donc il est en train
de Fr frurer la société à dessin son but
c'est de fracturer la société en faire
des miettes et ramasser les miettes pour
se retrouver avec une société où plus
personne n'est d'accord où au final il
peut avir la théorie du chaos et arriver
au pouvoir grâce à cette théorie du
chaos c'est ça le sujet et il y a même
pire c'est que la France insoumise est
en train de faire un discours de
contrreevérité quand on a le débat par
exemple sur l'hôpital de la bande de
Gaza Mathilde pano la présidente du
groupe LFI à l'Assemblée nationale dit
quoi elle dit pas pardon j'ai fait un
tweet j'étais trop vite je m'excuse elle
dit quoi qu'il se passe quelle que soit
la vérité je continue de croire que
c'est Israël qui a envoyé le missile
contre toutes les preuves qui ont été
apportées c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui de la France insoumise
c'estàdire qu'ils sont prêts pour mettre
les Français dans la rue et en
particulier les jeunes Français
musulmans dans la rue ils sont prêts à
mentir avoir un discours de contrevérité
pour fracturer la société et Orter moi
je pense pas je pense qu'il rendre
service à personne et surtout pas au
Palestiniens et surtout pas au
Palestiniens c'est ce qu'il faut dire
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est une arnaque
intellectuel d'abord pour les
Palestiniens ou pour tous ceux français
ou autres qui veulent évid un État
palestinien à côté de l'État israélien
pourquoi moi je vais vous dire moi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il ne veut pas d'état
palestinien Jean-Luc Mélenchon je vous
le dit que ce soit en France que ce soit
au moy au Proche Orient tout ça il veut
le chaos partout c'est par le chaos qui
se dit qu'il peut prendre le pouvoir je
le dis et ici on le voit je le vois ici
écoutez il y a Raymon qui me disait il y
a 2 secondes quand il y avait les gilets
jaunes qui c'est qui leur disait de
descendre dans la rue et de sortir dans
la rue il a pris et lui dès dès que ça
chauffait il se faisait exfiltrer il
reste pas longtemps dans les manifest
prend
cou fait croire que la France est du
côté israélien mais c'est insupportable
au regard de l'istoire Shirak était un
ami d'Arafat les les socialistes ont
toujours été très proches et la gauche
d'une façon générale a toujours été très
pr à Monsieur Méch reg le tweet Emmanuel
Macron qui par en israë demain on va
remettre ce tweet parce que je veux que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon j' rien qu'il le lise
à haute voix le tweet que sur Emmanuel
Macron sur ce qu'il va faire demain
merci réveillez-vous en régie oui j'aime
bien ce t
sa
cris
laonisation c'est
quocron et je dis et moi je dis vous
savez je dis les choses et j'ai jamais
été pour le gouvernement je trouve que
le gouvernement actuel franchement je
trouve qu'il font le taf je suis désolé
les gars sur ce sujet là il ils font le
taf et Emmanuel
Macron pe je dire on peut très tranqu
avec beaucoup de fermeté et de
tranquillité parler
d'occupation israélienne dans un certain
nombre d'endroits de parler de tentativ
de
colonisation en Cisjordanie sans
insulter Israël et tout en en étant un
soutien de l'État d'Israël ce que je
suis on peut être en désaccord profond
très dur avec le gouvernement avec
l'Alliance d'extrême droite de Benjamin
nat et je crois en plus que les
Israéliens après ce qui s'est passé vont
régler cette question par que c'est
quand même une démocratie mais on n pas
besoin d'aller dans cette fuite en
avant totalement folle
irresonsable jouant sur les codes de
l'antisémitisme comme le fait Jean-Luc
mélchon je veux dire on n pas étonné on
est choqué mais on est pas étonné parce
que il a pris la ligne du populisme il
s'adresse à certain nombre de mythes à
gauche sur cette question palestinienne
et ce ne serait pas aussi grave si ça
concernait seulement Monsieur Mélenchon
mais la vraie
difficulté c'est qu'il entraîne toute la
gauche exactement vers quoi vers une
marginalisation durable de toute la
gauche politique si d'aventure les
partis membres de laanupes ne prononcent
pas une rupture et une clarification
nette avec les propos la stratégie et la
méthode pas simplement de Monsieur
Mélenchon mais de la direction
majoritaire de la France insoumise c'est
d'une gravité absolu parce que ce pays a
besoin d'une opposition qui soit sur les
principes républains Tom pas dans un
disc politique non plus voilà restons
vraiment sur le cas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je vous dis Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous me
disiez un truc jeanluc Mélenchon il y a
10 ans il était mais a 10 ans Jean-Luc
Mélenchon allit sur les plateaux c'était
le républicain Laï bouffur de voile
enfin il voulait pas voir un voile dans
la r pas dans la rue jeanluc mélchon il
y a 10s je vous dis depuis qu'il a cé
ver le populisme c'est la fuite en avant
tout est per aujourdui la France
insoumis ça devient un mouvement qui est
séditieux et facieux voilà faut appeler
les choses ils veulent fracturer la
société pour avoir gain électoral moi je
suis désolé mais au bout d'un moment on
va quand même devoir se poser la
question la disolution de la
France
question je pense qu'il va falloir se
poser la question de la dissolution de
la France mais pourquoi mes amis là M
amis musulmans m'écrivent tous il me dis
c'est les seuls qui nous
défendent PL faut dire les choses ici
mes potes musulans il
dis les seul qui nous défendent c'est la
francemise donc pourquoi on serait
contre eux ça un moment ça veut dire
quoi défendre des musulmans je cro c'est
fa se il disent il me disent c'est les
seuls qui les défendent ils on ils ont
le sentiment ils ont les non mais pas il
parle pas de ça il par parle même
d'avant il parle d'avant il
par jeanluc Mélenchon il a fait le plein
sur les musulmans à la dernière
élection PL s PL s vous pla s'il vous
plaît merci non non mais je vous le dis
juste pourquoi tous les musulmans on
sentiment que la France insoumise est le
seul parti qui leur
parle parce que c'est vrai parce que
c'est vrai c'est pas un sentiment c'est
une réalité les gens gens donne-moi des
exemples je comprends
pas les seuls les seuls qui les seuls
qui pensent que le gouvernement français
est univoque et proisraélien les seuls
qui pensent qu'il faut dénoncer les
bombardements israéliens sur Gaza je
suis désolé c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
la France insoumise que vous voulez ou
non mais c'est vrai monsieur c'est pas
vous attendre de voir la la
visite on va attendre voir la visite du
président parce qu'il parle quand même
d'arrêt d'arrêt de colonisation c'est un
mot fort pour le président français et
surtout c'est à la gauche come ça vous
arrange pas la gauche de faire le ménage
et de faire une fracture avec la France
insoumise de les renvoyer dans leur
cordes haineus parce que c'est un
discours tu sujet excuse-moi mon ch oh
oh tais-toi calme-toi je te parlais
d'avant je te parlais pas de maintenant
je te parle même avant les élections
présidentielles la France insoumise on
avait le sentiment et les musulmans ont
le sentiment que c'est le seul parti qui
leur parle et qui s'adresse à eux et qui
pour qui il compte donc c'est c'est vra
ou pas ils ont raison parce que sur les
médias sur les médias nous nous on a
parlé ici de la Palestine sur les médias
même vous tout à l'heure vous avez dit
je soutiens Israël mais on entend nulle
part je soutiens la Palestine on
condamne le Hamas attendez tous les m
mais je sais bien mais il le dit pas
mais il pas ditend la prière chose que
j'ai dit je suis pour oui mais les mais
on s on on s'appuie sur le twet le tweet
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est qui est très
bien son tweet et moi je pense que pour
contrer Jean-Luc Mélenchon attendez
attendez pour contrer Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il faudrait que les les tout tout ce
qu'on parle des musulmans il faudrait se
baser sur ça sur ce tweet là parce que
ça c'est de l'espoir c'est mieux que non
mais c'est pas à vous mais surtous les
plateaux en général si je mets la télé
moi tout le weekend et depuis 10 jours
on a on on entend beaucoup de trucs qui
disent voilà je soutiens l'Israël et on
entend pas beaucoup je soutiens la
Palestine non l'entend moi
sin moi je
voulais
pasamp
arrivéaz pardon mais Israël n'est pas en
guerre avec la Palestine Israël est en
guerre avec ramas qui est une
organisation terroriste qui est de la
bande de Gaza d'ailleurs l'Autorité
palestinienne de Mahmoud Abbas le fata
n'a aucune autorité sur la bande de Gaza
la seule autorité qu'ils ont c'est
qu'ils vont leur donner 3 millions
d'euros enfin de dollars pour avoir pour
remercier les familles des kamikas qui
sont allés tuer les
Ju parce fait regarde toutes les grandes
stars françaises qui ont pris la parole
c'est juste pour le pour le peuple
palestinen qui ont pris la parole
lesalouf
benzemaon un qui me dit la majorité des
musulmans et moimême on a rien à [__]
de la
exement et il n il fait populisme comme
lesam le r comprend pourquoi il é
islamophobe aussi je comprends pas plus
qu'il était islamophobe ça veut dire
quoi en fait je pense pas qu'il était
islamophobe mais il dit ça avant si
avant il était contre le voile et C il
vou pas il vou pas oui on va pas rentrer
dans un débat dès que à chaque mot vous
allez rentrer dans un débat a rien à
faire des musulmans ou pas musul la
réalité c'est que c'est un Pact
électoral pour lui dans une stratégie
totalement moi ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est que c'est une illusion de croire
que c'est comme ça qu'on mobilise les
quartiers populaires les banlieux et y
compris les Français issus de
l'immigration je parle d'expérience je
suis j'étais membre d'un parti le Parti
socialiste où on a fait les meilleurs
scores dans les banlieux françaises
qu'on avait le vote si vous voulez y
compris des Français issus de
l'immigration parce que pourquoi pas
parce qu'on venait caresser dans le sens
du poil les gens parce qu'ils étaient
musulmans on venait porter des projets
pour la société des améliorations
sociales pour les conditions des
personnes modestes parce qu'on parla
progrs et qu'on s'atqu à
qui c'est une er c'est une erreur de
croire qu'on va drainer une population
avec ce type de discours il va
perdre juste un truc faitque on peut
dire comme j'ai dit laère fois on peut
dire je suis je suis je suis avec les
Israéliens je suis avec les Palestiniens
je suis pour la Palestine je suis pour
Israël on peut pas dire je suis pour le
Hamas c'est comme si tu disais je suis
pour DAEs possible mais voilà la
franceise d'accvec d'accord avec toi moi
ils mett de l'huile sur le feu les manif
ça se passe super bien les manifes qu'il
a pour la Palestine ça se passe super
bien et eux ils mettent de l'huile sur
le feu moi j'ai condamné le héta dans pr
c'est les musulmans que vous évoquez qui
se sentent représentés par jeanlut mchon
se sent vraiment représentés quand
envoie un homme qui aspire au plus haute
fonction de la République écrire ce
qu'ilune fonction je sais mais c'est ce
qu'il ve lu fonction c'est donner son
avis il veut
liser Cyr Cyril il il y a 2 3 ans ce
qu'il écrivait ça passait pas 2 secondes
c'est inadmissible ce qui a été ce qui a
été écrit il y a aucun homme politique
aucune femme politique il se serait
permis d'écrire ça et et il prend si
c'est ligne rouge on va aller jusqu'ù
moi moi j'ai envie de pleurer de cette
situation de ce qu'il veut mettre en
France le chos effectivement qui mais
camp camp les mots qu'il a utilisé ça
serait jamais passé de 3 an le P jeanmar
qui duur crématoire et cetera alors
quand même c'était à l'extrême droite on
trouvait ça logique qu'il soit
antisémite c'était les héritiers des
nazis mais à gauche Jean-Luc Mélenchon
utiliser les procédés de Jean-Marie Le
Pen per franchement c'est une douleur
absol on va voir le sondage s'il vous
plaît voilà 58 % oui et 41 % c'est plus
partagé qu'ici je trouve c'est plus
partagé qu'ici exactement magg merci